parole vivante elisabeth de la baie à
votre écoute enchanté et une
entrepreneure saison ça voilà c'est un
copain d'être un leader se réjouissent
bonjour à tous et à toutes et bienvenue
pour un peu moins de deux heures de
dialogue
je t'avoue paris un homme en jeu mérite
c'est l'été et messieurs merci plaisir
août 10 points nous avons julien
téléphone pour je voudrais dire quelque
chose à ma mère mais je n'ose pas je
pense que je suis amoureux dans l'autre
dieu être dedans de nous mon fils n'est
pas incapable
efféminé c'était preuve de rapprocher de
dieu tu as la chance de vous rappeler
qu'en accusant sans preuve iker a few
vous commettez de pêcher de médias
qui pressent pour une liseuse madame de
la radio et son prix
mais si une liste d'accusations
calomnieuses
elisabeth vous voulez venir boire le thé
à la maison après la fête
non je suis désolé mais j'ai déjà
quelque chose de prévu
jésus c'est un super gars drôle tire pas
sur un noyau sable
je cherche le père d'arzacq
pardon et d'amis étudiants pour toi et
pour ta famille ici maintenant et
jusqu'au dernier nous
non